the biggest hospital in maputo
is also the busiest health facility in
mozambique
and the central di maputo always
operates at full capacity
but the pandemic has arrived in this
african hub
and it's put this place under
considerable strain
we are working on this big trend to add
more patients here
and really we
already had this one for the last three
weeks i think
just to increase the number of the beds
and we have 20
patients that are here dr lucia shambal
may have trained in internal medicine
but now she's erecting
tents and securing supplies in her role
as
covid coordinator on the first wave it
was not that bad
we didn't have so many deaths but
this second wave is hard
getting hard for us the rate of
infection in mozambique
has shot upwards doubling says the
government
over the past three weeks yet most here
think that's an
underestimate and hospital central
is dealing with the consequences are you
surprised that you
you got sick yes dangerous
don't give don't give you don't give
time
you feel like something slowly like
event hey have you had contact with your
family
no no contact with your family
it must be hard must
[Music]
most mozambicans including the people
who run this country
thought they had dodged the global
pandemic
that changed in december when people
came here for the holidays
bringing gifts supplies and the south
african variant
so that's some people coming tomorrow
to holiday
so the things turned like this
you think they they brought it here i
believe so
very scary and dangerous
caught unprepared other hospitals in the
city
are putting up wards run by newly
qualified
staff as they struggle with a surge in
admissions
an emergency response that will soon be
required
by other african states we will probably
have this
variant that circulating like all over
the sub-saharan africa
they have to like be like in front of
the problem
just to not have like a burnout of the
system
in an attempt to contain the virus
mozambique's president
has implemented a curfew and a
prohibition on private events
but it's difficult to ask people to stay
at home
if we stay at house we'll stay angry you
understand
we'll die we'll not die about coffee and
die about
angry angry yes so we scared more about
hungry
more than coffee and the introduction of
vaccines
is unlikely to provide a solution in an
impoverished nation
of 30 million we spoke to the
coordinator
of a prominent public health charity
how long would it take for every
mozambican to receive a vaccine
months years at least three to five
years to arrive
at three to five years that's a long
time that's a long time
you can have people living 50 kilometers
from
maputo city but never for 50 years never
arrived to muratu
they lived there and won't come to just
to
vaccination in hospital central
they are doing their best with donated
tense
and inexperienced staff and oxygen
trucked in from south africa
but they can't do much more than this
john sparks sky news
in maputo